president biden meets today with
afghanistan's president to discuss
the ongoing u.s military withdrawal
charlie dagetta is in afghanistan where
the government is under severe pressure
and there is rising concern for
thousands of people who worked with the
u.s military
during 20 years of war good morning
good morning president ashraf ghani's
visit to the white house comes as this
country
enters its most critical period since
the u.s
invasion now here's the reality on the
ground
the taliban has made huge military
advances across the country in recent
months
the un says the militant group has
captured more than 50 of the country's
370 districts
some estimates are much worse the
taliban says
afghan soldiers are simply surrendering
and abandoning their posts without a
fight
now those advances have accelerated
since the u.s pull out sped up
last month and u.s military sources tell
us that mission
will be complete by early to mid july
however
the fate of 18 000 interpreters and
their families facing taliban death
threats
for helping the americans hangs in the
balance president biden vowing to get
them out of the country
a mammoth task that will certainly
depend on the us military
in today's meeting at the white house
ashraf ghani will be discussing
the new relationship with america in
terms of economic and humanitarian
assistance
but what's needed most here is
substantial
military assistance and those days are
over
charlie dagetta force in afghanistan
thank you